Robert Spencer here for Jihad watch a
program of the David harwoods Freedom
Center and for the center for security
policy I'm here to tell you what the
mainstream media won't tell you the
truth about the Council on American
Islamic relations that is care the first
thing you need to know about care is
that Belling its universally accepted
claim to be simply a Muslim civil rights
organization it was actually founded by
members and Associates of the Jihad
terror group Hamas in order to support
Hamas in the United States according to
testimony of FBI agents and documents
submitted as evidence in federal trial
care was founded after an October 1993
meeting in Philadelphia of the Palestine
committee which the Department of
Justice described as a covert
organization established by members of
the Muslim Brotherhood in the United
States in order to support Hamas a 1994
Palestine committee documents submitted
at a federal trial identifies care as
one of the Palestine committee's working
organizations care had been founded that
same year by nihad Awad and Omar ammed
an FBI affidavit obtained by a Freedom
of Information Act request identifies
Omar ammed as one of the leaders of
Hamas the same affidavit notes that
Palestine committee members were also
active us Muslim Brotherhood members
akmed and nihad wad were both named by
the FBI during a federal trial as
Palestine committee members both men's
names appear in a phone book of
Palestine committee members that was
submitted as evidence at this same
federal
trial care was a spin-off of a Hamas
front group the Islamic Association for
Palestine or the IAP nihad Awad had been
the I ap's president and Omar ammed its
public relations director the IAP in
itself was found founded in 1981 by a
Hamas operative named Musa Abu marzuk
and was shut down in 2005 by the US
government for funding terrorism
according to an August 14th 2001 report
from the immigration and naturalization
services the IAP was dedicated to
publishing and distributing Hamas
communic printed on IAP letterhead as
well as other written documentation to
include the Hamas Charter and Glory
records which are tributes to hamas's
violent successes that is celebrations
of hamas's murders of Israeli civilians
the same report also stated that the IAP
had received approximately
$490,000 from Musa Abu marzuk During the
period in which marzuk had held his
admitted role as a Hamas leader a former
Chief of the FBI's counterterrorism
Department Oliver Revel called the IAP a
front Organization for Hamas that
engages in propaganda for Islamic
militants nihad Awad initially made no
secret of his affinity for Hamas in 1994
at Barry University in Florida Awad
openly proclaimed I'm in support of
Hamas movement as a result of these
connections the FBI eventually formally
cut its association with care and given
all this the fact that care nevertheless
still enjoys some government and law
enforcement officials ear and is treated
as a go-to source by the mainstream
media which always presents it as a
civil rights organization without ever
disclosing its ties to Hamas is nothing
short of scandalous and it must end much
more to come about care I'm Robert
Spencer of jihad watch